[Music]
on this Friday night a diluted
resolution to ramp up Aid deliveries
into Gaza what the UN Security Council
approved this was tough and what's not
included demanding answers this is a
huge breach of trust reaction to a
global news investigation about the
reliability of the covid rapid test the
FED spent billions on and the British
teen missing for 6 years tells his story
I was safe and I was always healthy how
his mother and grandfather allegedly
abducted him and why the boy
escaped global national with foreign
Asser good evening to you thanks for
joining us after days of delays the UN
Security Council has passed down a
watered down version of a resolution to
boost humanitarian Aid to Gaza it calls
for Urgent steps to allow safe and
unhindered humanitarian access but the
big question is will it make a
difference on the ground Israel has
ignored un resolutions in the past and
for some the language in this one
doesn't go far enough this resolution is
a step in the right direction it must be
implemented and must be accompanied by
Massive pressure for an immediate
ceasefire I repeat immediate
ceasefire and the help can't come
quickly enough pales indan Health
officials in Gaza now say the death toll
there has surpassed 20,000 that's nearly
1% of gaza's pre-war population it says
70% of those killed are women and
children Jackson prco now on the crisis
and the resolution to
help the desperation in Gaza is
unfathomable with more buildings reduced
to Rubble by Israeli air strikes food
and water are so limited the UN warns
there's a risk of wide spread
famine this is brutal says this man
whose relatives were killed I'm asking
if the UN can accept this after days of
intense negotiations the UN took the
first steps toward relief there must be
an international response the security
Council passed a watered down
humanitarian resolution this was
tough but we got there it calls for a
major and immediate increase in Aid to
Gaza today this Council
provided a glimmer of hope amongst a sea
of unimaginable
suffering the resolution does not demand
a ceasefire nor does it condemn the
October 7th attack by Hamas exensions
both the US and Russia abstain to allow
it to pass let's not reject this
resolution the deal was brokered by the
United Arab Emirates and Falls far short
of what the UN Secretary General says is
needed the real problem is that the way
Israel is conducting this offensive is
creating massive obstacles to the
distribution of humanitarian Aid inside
Gaza Israel is not yet ready to change
course the operation is gradually
completing the goals we set said
Israel's defense minister as civilians
in central Gaza were told to move
further south gaza's Health Ministry
says 20,000 people have been killed and
another 53,000 wounded Canada has said
it will grant extended visas to families
of Canadian citizens and permanent
residents in Gaza to help them
flee if Aid can flow through it may ease
some of the immense suffering but Hamas
says there will be no ceasefire until
Israel withdraws its troops Israel says
that will not happen until Hamas
surrenders Jackson prco Global News
Washington and there is new information
tonight involving missing Canadian
Israeli Jud Judy Weinstein and her
husband G huggi the hostages in missing
person's Family Forum says Judy is still
being held half captive by Hamas it also
confirms the death of her husband and
says his body is still being held in
Gaza by Hamas their daughter spoke to
Global News in early December and says
her father was murdered and her mom was
shot twice the pair was out for a walk
when attacked by Hamas the morning of
October 7th Hamas has not confirmed the
accounts but does warn that time is
running out for the hostages the war in
Israel is nearing now its 12th
week to Prague next MERS are paying
tribute to 14 people killed yesterday in
the city's worst mass shooting the prime
minister of the Czech Republic visited
the impromptu Memorial outside the
city's Charles University the government
had declared December 23rd a day of
mourning for the victims yesterday a
24-year-old student opened fire at the
school the gunman killed 14 people
before shooting himself three foreign
Nationals are among the 25 wounded no
Canadians are said to be
affected there has been plenty of
reaction to a global news investigation
into covid-19 rapid tests procured by
the federal government during the height
of the pandemic the kits in the lime
green box became ubiquitous across the
country but after digging into the story
for more than a year our journalists
found evidence that the test supplier
Toronto based btnx gave Health Canada in
complete data about its accuracy now the
company is denying the allegations but
as Heather yorx West reports those that
worked on the front lines of the
pandemic say Canadians deserve
answers it's a lime green box that's
become familiar to most Canadians the
kits have been used to test for covid
millions of times I think that everyone
uh so many people I know uh including
myself have relied upon these tests uh
to make decisions for our own health and
and that of our loved ones and and that
of uh of other members of the public
it's why there are questions after a
global news investigation revealed
evidence that the rapid tests importers
Toronto based btnx submitted incomplete
data to health Canada about the tests
accuracy in response to Global news's
questions btnx described its tests as a
reliable testing tool for Canadians for
its part Health Canada said it found no
reason to question the scientific
integrity of the studies btnx submitted
if you have a higher percentage of false
negative tests it can obviously drive
people to make decisions that they may
not would have otherwise made and you
know that can clearly result in Greater
transmission of of
infection the world may have moved
beyond the pandemic but CO's threat has
not gone away and for those planning to
come in contact with the medically
vulnerable rapid tests are regularly
requested at this Pharmacy oh yeah
definitely people are still looking for
it for that reason they act as a guide
whether there is a covid case or not the
head of Manitoba's Health Coalition says
governments need to follow up on what
the global news investigation revealed
this is a huge breach of trust uh in the
public health care System um in my in my
personal opinion and it's something that
we should be demanding answers from we
should be demanding answers from the
federal government about this and the
provinces what they knew btnx says it
did not offer help Canada or Canadians
inaccurate information about the rapid
test the Prime Minister told global news
that his government still has lessons to
learn about the pandemic but did not
specify whether those lessons involved
the btnx rapid test Heather urix West
Global News
Calgary and prime minister Justin
Trudeau is expressing concern over
Canada's military Readiness this is in
light of his government's push to help
support security efforts overseas and
this rare acknowledgement came during a
year-end interview with our Ottawa
bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson where he
discussed the state of the Canadian
Armed Forces Mercedes far this year has
been a huge eye opener for many
Canadians about the state of Canada's
military at the beginning of the year we
all remember the Chinese spy balloon
that flew into Canadian and US airspace
and then of course there were the close
run-ins with China in the South China
Sea add to all that the conflict that
has broken out in the Middle East and
the ripple effect on the region
Canada has found itself Limited in how
it can respond as houthi Rebels have
targeted ships transiting the Red Sea
the Canadian government has been
restrained to sending only a handful of
personnel to operation Prosperity
Guardian instead of a full ship because
we simply don't have one available in my
year-end interview with prime minister
Justin Trudeau I asked him about the
Canadian military's Readiness he goes
further than what I've heard him say
before acknowledging that the Canadian
Armed Forces are struggling and he
argues that helping Ukraine has been a
factor in stripping the military
cupboards bear chief of the defense
staff is saying that if there were to be
a war tomorrow Canada would be in big
trouble isn't that on you after eight
years in power everyone is in in big
trouble because we have been shipping
all of us as allies as NATO allies
shipping massive amounts of ammunition
to Ukraine right now because Ukraine is
on the front line of Defending not just
their own territory but the
international rules-based order and
that's why we are so unequivocal on
Ukraine and quite frankly even yes as
we're fixing those procurement
challenges to make sure we are getting
more ammunition for Canada for training
uh continuing to be there for Ukraine
despite the hesitations uh by the
conservative party uh is the best way to
protect uh our future as a country and
our our our system of democracy of
course it is up to the government of the
day to replace equipment that has been
shipped overseas and the prime minister
says that more defense spending is
coming we'll see if that happens in the
spring budget far Mercedes Stevenson in
Ottawa thank you Mercedes and you can
watch mercedes's full interview with the
Prime Minister on a special edition of
the West block this Sunday morning on
global there are growing calls to
drastically increase Canada's electric
vehicle charging infrastructure this
after the federal government laid out
its goal to phase out the sale of new
gas and Diesel powered passenger
vehicles by 203 5 an ambitious plan that
will require more than just making EVS
more widely available to Canadians
Abigail Bean explains L 5586 that's me
David Howell uses one of the 57
app-based Chargers in his Toronto
condo's parking garage $3 to $400 a
month for for gas now with this car at
night it's $2 for every 100 kilometers
you drive and that's that's a game Cher
how ow is part of a condo success story
but about a third of Canadians live in
apartments many without easy charging
access switch energy is focused on that
challenge that was something that was
never part of their initial build and so
the electrical infrastructure required
to have EV Chargers um taking a lot of
electrical Demand on a daily basis is
one of the biggest problems that
everyone has to face the more North you
get I would say the the kind of um more
sparse the infrastructure gets another
challenge rural Canada Deon Arthur says
it's not just about building the
infrastructure the reliability piece I
think is is going to be increasingly
important you know we've already seen
issues up north where stations AR
working people get stranded even though
as many as 80% of people are expected to
charge at home a report done for Natural
Resources Canada found in order to meet
the 2035 goal we need about half a
million public chargers for now the feds
have committed to funding 43,000 and
promised they'll all be up and running
within the next 18 months the government
tells global news new projections about
how many public Chargers are needed will
come in the New Year meanwhile some
experts think the half a million number
is inflated unless the electric vehicles
really become a lot more economic this
is not going to happen at that rate
Energy Systems expert claudo canizares
says we will have enough electricity to
power everyone but not without some kind
of time of use system to regulate
charging and costly upgrades to change
over distribution Transformers we're
going to need more electricity if we
keep having cars and heat pumps the
feedback that I get is that they're well
aware of this we've got a decent time
frame to be able to do it about 60% of
electrician Mark Marr's business is now
installing Chargers he says a little
creativity can go a long way like this
Toronto Church which installed six in
their parking lot hoping to help many
neighbors who rely on street parking
Abigail Bean Global News Ottawa a
heartbroken family's Quest For answers
from the Health Care System coming up
the pressure for an investigation into
an indigenous woman's
death back in September we spoke with
the parents of November Kelly an Ontario
indigenous woman who died of a severe
infection that they along with a growing
number of doctors say should have been
caught and should have being treated our
baby would be here if they would
have listened to her I do believe and I
feel that she was racially
profiled an Ontario MPP is now calling
for an investigation into the young
mother's death while one physician says
reviews and investigations still haven't
addressed the root cause of the problem
that indigenous patients in this country
continue to receive worse Health Care
than other Canadians Melissa Ren reports
the Kelly family is facing their first
Christmas without their loved one but
finding strength in a growing number of
supporters demanding answers their
daughter November Kelly died last
February when a perforated bowel
sustained in a car crash went undetected
for 4 months despite multiple trips to
doctors in Fort Francis Ontario
something this doctor says shouldn't
have happened that is really sad that
kid probably she suffered you know she
suffered Dr Barry lavy is an indigenous
physician in Winnipeg who was on a
working group that looked into the death
of Brian Sinclair a first nation's man
who died from a bladder infection in a
Winnipeg emergency room in 2008 lav
believes November Kelly is the latest
name on a list of patients who didn't
need to die it's part of the Joyce Squan
story it's part of the um uh Brian
Sinclair story okay because their
ability to probably be truly uh an
equity lens in medicine was not there
krie Kelly says her daughter felt
unheard and brushed off when she sought
Care at one point given a fiber
supplement and sent home it was hard for
me to get her to go because of the way
she was treated when she would go sa
mamaka is the ndp's indigenous Affairs
critic in Ontario racism
kills discrimination
kills um colonialism kills and I think
that this is a prime example mqu wants
Ontario's indigenous Minister Greg
rickford to press for a broader
investigation than the one that is
underway by the health authority in Fort
Francis rickford hasn't responded to
Global News on whether he would do that
the Ontario College of Physicians
insurgents confirms that they've
received a complaint about the care that
November Kelly received but Moka says
everyone who had contact over those many
months should be part of an
investigation not just doctors believing
the entire system failed November the
intent would be you know um that it does
not have to again the Kelly Family hopes
2024 will bring them answers Melissa Rin
Global News
Winnipeg he was missing for six years so
what happened ahead of British teens
mysterious Journey back into
[Music]
[Applause]
society Nirvana's 1991 Album never mind
is once again making headlines the US
court has revived a lawsuit accusing the
rock band of publishing child
pornography on the cover of that album
which has sold more than 30 million
copies Spencer Elden now 32 had a
previous lawsuit dismissed because of
the statute of limitations appeals court
reversed that decision noting the album
had been reissued in
2021 a British teen who resurfaced last
week after being missing for six years
is opening up about his mysterious life
abroad Alex mdty is now back in the UK
after disappearing in Spain with his
mother and grandfather in
2017 the now 17-year-old says he
initially lied to authorities about his
return to society to protect his family
but is now revealing some of the
intricate details about his time away
from home Chrystal ganing
reports like the winding Rural Road
where the teen was spotted the twists in
Alex bad's story are coming into Focus
hello Grandma it's me Alex I'm in
France this French delivery driver was
the first person to help Alex reconnect
with his family in the UK this is what
the 17-year-old looked like the last
time his grandmother saw him he was
reported missing in
2017 after he and his mother disappeared
while on vacation the case captured
headlines around the world I thought I
should stop and ask him if he was okay
or even just help him or at least bring
him back to a village back to
civilization as quickly as possible
getting Alex back to civilization is
exactly what the teen had in mind he'd
been living off the grid with his mother
and grandfather for six years first in
Spain and then in France in an interview
with the son he shared his story about
going on vacation with his mom and the
years since I was safe and I was always
healthy but um no social life no meeting
people my own age kind of always being
isolated
comes boring to say the least really an
investigation is underway into the
circumstances of Alex's disappearance
his return was celebrated last week by
authorities this moment was undoubtedly
huge for him and his loved ones Alex may
have spent years being bored and feeling
isolated but he's quickly becoming the
center of attention Crystal ganing
Global News
London Oh What A Difference A year makes
next a Christmas wish comes true for
travelers today is expected to be the
busiest shopping day of the year making
it a bad time for payment processing
machines to go down but that's what
happened Monas confirmed this afternoon
that it was experiencing a service
degradation so Shoppers that were trying
to use credit or debit cards were unable
to complete transactions across Canada
the problem has now been fixed and the
Friday before Christmas is also known as
the busiest travel day of the year many
Canadians with memories of the chaos of
last year are pleasantly surprised to
see fewer disruptions and delays this
year as NE Gara reports milder weather
is helping ensure this holiday goes a
little
smoother jingle bells jingle
the busiest travel day of the year is
usually synonymous with stress but this
year is different for many like The
Robertson's it's fun to hang out at the
airport at
Christmas at the Calgary Airport she
welcomed her son who says his journey
from Ontario was all smooth this couple
on a layover heading back home to BC
from Palm Springs says the same last
year we spent 3 days here in Calgary
with the weather so we're just really
thankful that it's much better at
Vancouver International Airport so far
so good yeah I'm surprised after last
year's severe weather induced holiday
travel chaos with canceled flights
missing baggage and passengers stuck on
planes YVR CEO says lessons were learned
everything from new technology and
equipment on the Airfield to new
processes with our Airlines in terms of
how they move and handle aircraft and
move baggage at Toronto Pearson
International Airport Staffing levels
and snow removal equipment have been
ramped up from last year so far so good
we're just tired but looking forward to
some warm weather easy day easy day
hopefully it is warmer across the
country on BC's famous Whistler Mountain
they had to make snow skiers are
expressing their frustration but it is
good news for air
Travelers Merry Christmas despite the
lack of disruptions and delays seen last
year volume is higher at many airports
reminding passengers to plan accordingly
and to be patient or as this Duo does
make the most of the time Nea Global
News
Vancouver and that's global national for
this Friday night I'm faranas and on
behalf of our whole crew here I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your Friday evening with us tonight's
here Canada is the Lobster Pot Christmas
tree in North Sydney Nova Scotia until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
take care of each other good night
[Music]